[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about
whatever we want anthony lee is back and
engaged
that's an announcement how does it feel
it feels good it feels like you unlock a
different level you know what i mean
yeah because before it was just like
nothing but insecurity for like years
yeah security
is this gonna be the one no way what
kind of insecurity you know just like
it's like this is gonna be the person
i'm gonna share my food with the rest of
my life
yeah this is gonna be the person that i
always have to like you share my bed
with
where i'm always like sleeping this much
on the bed she's like everywhere
no i'm just kidding i love it it does it
does feel like for some reason
anybody who's married um help me out
here with this
it does feel like there's like a secret
level that's just unlocked it does feel
different
and like trust and intimacy and stuff
like that just kind of like
i don't know i don't know how to trust
her before get the [ __ ] out of here
she might steal my money but the
announcement is ring it's our money
what if she can't steal what we both
have because i think everyone has a
different experience of unlocking right
like what is your unlocking experience
like
now you're you're telling your instagram
password now yeah i don't know no like
the energy
the energy's different like i feel like
um like the farts just get louder
i'm talking about like open yeah
everything's just more open yeah
everything's just a lot more like
it's like it's like if the walls weren't
down before
for whatever reason there's like maybe
an
invisible wall that is just extra down
so did you feel like you've been
open and then after you got engaged
you're like i'm even opener that i
didn't know
i feel like i was already at 100
capacity but that's not because like i
wasn't it's not that i was at 80.
it was out i was 100 capacity for my
level i just wasn't like the next level
you weren't aware of the next level so
are you are you pooping with the door
open now because that's the ultimate
that's always happening to be honest are
you diarrhea
[Laughter]
right i know you've done that though i'm
a gentleman are you sure
yeah right i could do like a really you
know like a silent poop like a huge
log that doesn't make a lot of sounds or
anything like a soft serve yeah
you know what i mean and you i could
look it right in the eye if there's no
sound
but even if it's like a non-smelly [ __ ]
and it's just like really
but it's just loud sounds i'm like i'm
i'm kind of embarrassed the sounds are
worse actually sometimes you should go
in the toilet right and then like
and like let's say i'm being a gentleman
that day and i close the door
and it's one of those like like that
like it's just you just torpedo yeah no
there's no nothing coming you mean when
the gas
is just kind of like oh it resonates in
the toilet bowl
i'm like oh [ __ ] sounds way worse
hey come in here look at this come here
look at this there's nothing in here
were you guys dating before you got
engaged six years
yeah so that's like a good amount of
time it was that was
i i would arguably say though that like
uh anywhere from 40 to 50
of my time i wasn't in the country so
like there was actually i had
a three-year relationship kind of i had
this thing with nina where like um
i never spent more than three months at
a time in the country
uh and we had this uh interesting
relationship thing where um you know
when you uh you get really comfortable
with somebody after a while so then like
the thing starts to kind of like annoy
you a little bit
and then i bounce and then and then
suddenly like you know distance makes
the heart grow all fond and stuff
suddenly you come back and then you're
back in like honeymoon phase because you
haven't seen each other for a long time
because i'm also gone for like three
months
and then everything's like great for
like you know x period of time and then
afterwards you start getting a little
comfortable and then right when it's
about to be like you know settled like
you feel the argument coming and you're
like
see you're going to china i got a gig in
china
so like we never really get a chance to
like you know uh do that and then the
pandemic happens
oh [ __ ] she fought it all out and not
yet not only am i like
actually stuck in the country i'm like
in the same box of an apartment with her
like 24
7. so then this this test became like
the
there was definitely a part i mean i
totally admitted it there was definitely
a part where i was like
oh [ __ ] we're gonna find out for real so
it's gonna like for real work out
but then you know six seven months
through the pandemic suddenly i'm like
oh [ __ ] this is gonna work out you know
what i mean and it wasn't that i didn't
have faith before
it was just like super validated by like
giving me like a really
hardcore like you don't get to [ __ ]
around right now like uh
you you have to focus on whether or not
you're gonna make it through spending
like the rest of your life with this
person and
it was like a hyper focused moment and i
don't know it was just really fun so i
want you to tell the story of your
wedding and i want you to read it and
you're like you're like
and then after six months into the
pandemic i was like oh [ __ ]
this is going to work out
like while he's tearing and [ __ ] line oh
yeah oh this is going to work out
in a suit no it's great though so shake
it and and all of my peers who have been
married before always kind of like
allude to this like
next level yeah and you know if you're
not there you just you can't you can't
see it you know what i mean it's like
that homer simpson episode where he's
like climbing up the mountain
and then he finally passes that like
line of clouds only to see that the
mountain like
is way taller it's kind of like that i
used to call it homer simpson too
i never called it the simpsons growing
up i was always like oh did you see
homer simpson last night
oh the whole show honestly you know
homer since his son
when he talks over simpson's daughter
dude i totally get that because in case
i got engaged like it totally does
feel like you're by having this
this kind of commitment set in in motion
it's kind of like oh [ __ ] yeah like this
is it because we were already living
together we had a kid already i mean
like you know having isaac in the house
that's a whole nother
commitment and yeah like getting engaged
it totally feels different
for sure wish thank you for being there
yeah i was honored to be there
it was where did you go i got a way more
famous dancer who asked me to do
something oh yeah yeah that's right
i didn't even get invited
what did you do the proposal when yeah
last week right two weeks ago two weeks
oh so it's like fresh fresh
it was fresh right exactly uh we were so
it kind of came out of nowhere people
were like
were you planning this and i i feel like
i always
knew i was either going to do something
really basic like out of nowhere be like
jim and pam from the office
or very like just extravagant because
like i'm crazy
um and then it was actually about a
month and a half ago that unfortunately
we um
had to come to the terms that we were
going to lose our our studio
in la because you know pandemic is just
uh really tough on us so
when we're closing the complex we're
like what's like one last thing that we
want to do
and we're like well let's put together
kind of like a friends and family code
safe like showcase and just invite like
you know ourselves
to come perform for ourselves and give
one last kind of like hoorah
and so it was like the monday before
that show on friday
friday saturday it was like that monday
and suddenly i was like oh [ __ ]
all the variables are in play her whole
family's available
some of her friends are in town this is
the last time we get everybody in one
building
this is like maybe the only chance i
could do it so then i had to plan it
that whole week
um i was nervous as freak but it was it
was like beautiful it was it was like
everyone catch cover everyone
that's minimal dust damn that's dope man
was she like crying like oh my god
yeah she was hella crying but she also
knew how did she know what
one of her friends leaked out the info
what's the point they have a feeling
i [ __ ] up yeah intuition how did you
[ __ ] up because i was on a zoom meeting
and i'm like planning the showcase so
like everybody's talking on the zoo
meeting about like everything has to go
down for the showcase and it's one time
that
all your zoomies are at home so i'm like
nonchalantly talking about [ __ ]
and then i randomly i'm talking about
how like our parents are going to be
there
and then i catch myself on the zoom i'm
like and i know she's in the living room
everybody on zoomies look at me like oh
no
and that was on wednesday why she's so
[ __ ] nosy listen
it's her fault this is her fault she has
ears did she
did she turned around and you saw her
grinning she was already she already had
like her mask off like her makeup is all
good and stuff like that just like ready
when like the light like
so she knew yeah and her friend jolene
was like hey take off your messy
[ __ ] oh no that's like you know when all
the girls are saying like hey you got to
get your nails done it's like [ __ ]
covid like why the [ __ ] are people
getting their nails done
so their sister's like hey i'm gonna i
gotta go get my name people are so
obvious man the nails done is like the
number one thing right yeah like it's
like it's over
because you need the pictures with the
ring and you need to make sure your
nails are done yeah
i mean i wasn't even thinking like that
this guy doesn't even know bro this guy
i never even proposed sorry you've never
been engaged wait are you serious
no i never proposed nah they just
scheduled the wedding
that's kind of tight i just sent her a
google calendar anyway
want to get married question calendar
invite and then she said yes
i'm attending but i don't even he
organized a wedding and then she
accepted the google calendar she got to
save the day and was like what we're
getting married the more you know him
and the more it makes sense
yeah that does make sense he sent a
invitation like through the mail
and that's how she found out no did you
ask did you ask your parents for
permission yeah that i did so
via mail yeah no via google account text
message
today's video is brought to you by
opstar and upstart is super sick
because if any of you guys have ever
tried to take out a loan
it's a pain in the ass you got to go to
a bank you got to get your credit score
checked
and you got to do all these things
that's just based off of your fico score
they look at things more than just your
fico score because they take into
consideration
your whole person and by the time i get
the loan guess what i owe
20 000 more dollars because they took so
day long yeah and the interest rate
could be
really really high so um i might
actually look into upstart when we are
going to build
our backyard oh really once i move to
vegas yeah to see what the rates are
just see what the rates are is to
compare and i always think it's really
really good to compare like regardless
if you already have a good lender
or you know you can qualify for
something at the bank but the part that
i really like about it is that they're
going to look into it
just more than my fico score into my
education and everything and you can
in five minutes you can find out what
you qualify for so
you know it was extremely hard for me to
get a personal loan from my bank
even though it was easier for my
business loan it was so bizarre like the
way that the banking system
is like they don't give out personal
loans as
easily so this is a really good thing
especially for people who like
you know are in a tough situation or
just don't want to deal with
20 credit card payments and they just
want to do one easy payment
of one apr i think this is the way to go
yeah so find out how upstart can lower
your monthly payment
by going to upstart.com off the record
that's upstart.com
off the record loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
that is provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
off director and i went to i went to her
house to ask for like her parents
blessing
um when she wasn't there and i think
that was important to me because like
the whole family thing is really
important but then
between me and her i think since we knew
we were gonna get married since like
month one it just never became like a
thing to kind of follow the
usual steps so when we were talking
about getting married
um she just started planning and then
would just happen so i didn't even
propose or anything oh [ __ ] weird huh
that's pretty tight
that's really that's pretty tight i feel
like i'm [ __ ] up now they even got
married without rings
really yeah we got rings later like at
the wedding
did you guys get made in hawaii yeah and
there was no ring i wasn't wearing shoes
beach weddings do let something slide
like slides yeah and david mary does
this cool
yeah it was really chill yeah it was
like a two-minute ceremony oh [ __ ]
it was actually just david roasting both
of us for that yeah he really wants to
but if you're gonna do a wedding that's
how you gotta do it though yeah that was
fun
yeah and literally the morning of we
were all playing basketball
in the rain i think one of us got a text
like hey
we're gonna get married in like 15
minutes like hey guys gotta go back
oh my god and then they got dressed up
and after you got married were you like
standing with you and you're like okay
what do you guys want to do
you guys want a party no we had more
plans than that no after that our friend
did a hula dance for us and then we ate
food
i want food and then we went in the pool
did you get a page
it yeah
do you eat a pig a pig for it like no
oh no we got um no we didn't get a whole
pig we got
hawaiian catering which is pretty good
like shredded pork cool yeah
that was fun yeah it was quick it was
like really quick when i feel like i
[ __ ] up
why did you just get married like that
yeah no why why'd you like yeah
no rings no work you did an event and
everything you played about i think you
just didn't
invite plus basketball in the morning
yeah dude
your lady wouldn't have to get her nails
done two-minute ceremonies
this is like a new standard that he's
like what are you gonna do what's your
ideal wedding what do you think you're
gonna plan
oh that's hard is it because you feel
pressured to make her happy
and do what you think she wants
absolutely
oh well i mean but obviously i'm happy
about that
good thing this is on patreon it's not
it's not
it's live we can clean this up we're
live there's no editing in there good
thing she doesn't subscribe anyways
she doesn't watch her videos anyway
no no i think um to me
to me it's like especially during like a
year like this
it's really it's really dope to see her
be excited about stuff you know i mean
suddenly it's like
[ __ ] randomly i'm always just like
hearing [ __ ] like she's on the phone
with her sister talking about random
stuff like
like [ __ ] flowers and like table
settings and like
dresses and stuff and obviously um she's
happy and
at the same time obviously i'm like i
don't need to pay attention this is like
far off for me for now um but just the
idea of like being excited about
[ __ ] especially during this year is like
really really cool so i think that's
just something i just want to like
nurture and foster for her i'm actually
really
surprised to hear that i really pictured
you the type of groom that would be
like more involved more involved because
especially the way that you propose
and then the way that you organize
events and stuff like i would see you
have your hands in there i just
subtly slip in my you know your two
cents
i'm like yeah you can do whatever you
want here are your options
a or b what would be your ideal wedding
if
you could have it 100 year away and what
would be her idea here's the hard part
okay it feels 100 my way we gotta um
everyone's gonna fly that like if it was
100 in my way she
she first of all she's probably like
think about like the bridal party
she's gonna have maybe like six to nine
people
tops like very like i know all of them
they like very close
six to nine bridesmaids that's that a
lot
that's is it a lot okay well in the
concept of
like i think i had eight groomsmen i'm
about to get eight groups
for like 40. i would have my whole crew
up there
just to make a statement wow you know no
one in the audience look at the photo
you gotta have like you know bridesmaids
right here and then just like
like rose choir boys yeah but no no guys
in the audience though
it would just be like your parents all
their plus ones it's not special if
everyone can do it
that's like everyone being a millionaire
it can't happen and it would be very
boring we didn't have any at our
weddings i'm like i don't know
picking no bridal party no none because
there'll be nobody in the eye [ __ ] the
wrong way oh man i think it's a
preference
yeah totally preference because imagine
getting
eight to nine people to organize to get
their dresses
and then their outfits that's a
nightmare bro
people are cool with it yeah some people
that's what he does on a daily everyone
all the guys have to wear the same [ __ ]
yeah that's actually
so i think you should have because if
there's ever a blueprint to follow it's
your blueprint coordinating human beings
wearing the same stuff standing in a
spot
should be pretty simple that's what you
guys do all the time all we have to do
and all that do is stand there
i'm looking at them like five six seven
eight
yeah but i mean obviously that can't
happen um
uh if i were to have things a hundred
percent my way kova didn't exist
kova didn't exist well
she would perform for me i think it
would be so cliche for people especially
her family to expect some like
kendra's performance at the wedding well
she's a dancer too right cliche
like dancing experience yeah she does so
her and her whole family has to and her
mom has to perform for me that'll be
great oh that's tight
i'll be great before me i like that
perform for me yes perform
i gotta sit down and just enjoy it i
think um for once i get to be the
audience
you know like chinese vietnamese typical
weddings you know like you go to like a
[ __ ] seafood restaurant or something
yeah and then they give you money and
yeah so i would i would hope for a ton
of money
yeah that would be sick i was gonna say
like a guy's ideal wedding is a free one
right oh yeah cause like i think we're
all down to do whatever
it's just it hurts how [ __ ] much you
have to pay
the upfront for for one day for one
day's event yeah
for us it's like [ __ ] seriously well
back in the day they would have the
bride's
family when did that stop i like those
rules
well no before that talking like you got
married eight times in a row
sure that's true what's yeah joe sounds
like a real divorce
stop you would have to give the the
dowry though
so it would always so is it is it the
same amount like the value-wise
is it a balance like is it like it's a
net zero
[Laughter]
right it's like a balance right no
matter what you lose
yeah if you have a good wedding you
break even and then you get like an
airfryer or something
[Laughter]
yeah but then the chinese weddings
though you're supposed to get paid for
them so you kind of break even right
you know they go back into like the
kitchen room and they like ask how much
like the wedding costs in terms of all
the food and then they like divvy it up
so they only pay you enough to cover
like
just the food yeah so like which is like
else still sweet and nice and i'm very
thankful if anybody's watching
but so calculated though yeah it's like
hey just throwing
a little extra hey that's better than
other western weddings where you get
zero from the guests only like your
amazon registry
yeah just pay us in bitcoin you know
yeah [ __ ] yeah that's a real move
in mexican culture like the tradition is
for the
in during the reception there's like the
money dance where the breakfast oh yeah
yeah yeah and with a whole bunch of
money so that's a tradition
for my culture right but i didn't it was
weird to be like hey people bring cash
so we actually provided the cash for
people just to do it
yeah like just for like that kind of
makes sense the whole event of it
yeah you should combine all those
practices all the money making practice
for a wedding combine all the money
dance stuff at like filipino weddings
and stuff like that too
should have been like kim kardashian and
monetized off of the wedding
yeah get sponsors wedding brought to you
by kenji bang noodles
i'm down to get like a jk news sponsor
or something like that you know
at least the cameras we are looking for
sponsors of the record where it's at
anthony's wedding
this video is sponsored by jk films on
anthony's wedding yes dude i'll be sick
imagine our logo on your guys's like
suit and dress
all the sponsors have to beat that like
you're a race guy ty
yeah dude forget jk party you guys do jk
boomby you got barbell brigade all these
and then it's like there's a gym in the
corner yeah
dude's just working out and [ __ ] just
make me write a lot of photos
for the reception it's like barbell
brigade protein shakes for everybody
there's pre-workout before the party and
dancing
oh protein shakes and dancing
pre-workout and dancing rice balls
yeah dude that's a good idea i think you
guys are on something i think i'd be
sick
this is i think you guys have to do it
and then for your wedding since you're
gonna have a lot of people you have to
create a bubble so you'd have
like the nba bubble but for your wedding
that'd be cool that way you could have
40 people as there's like 14 days of
just all like jk sponsorship kim
kardashian's
birthday party on that private island i
don't really follow kim kardashian to be
honest
i have to because she's in the news you
got you got plans like a
tentative date for the wedding or no i
feel like it'll probably be something
like next spring
and i also feel like we'll probably be
in maui
i love maui yeah we got i got a lot of
family in hawaii uh she's got family in
hawaii too my parents were actually um
they met after they came over from the
war
uh they met in hawaii and got married
there and had my sister there
wow wait on maui uh in in oahu
at that time my family lives in maui
right now oh really
oh then i'm not your family your
family's in there too
like your family's gone to the west
no um so yeah just just a lot of history
there and just it would be dope to like
kind of like get that familial
connection
to bring into our new family family
cute how about kids do you guys have
your last name is lee so it's family
yeah that's our that's our group me
anyways
um kids yeah i keep on i feel like i'm
trying to i don't know if i'm ready for
it nobody's ever ready
but i feel like i i try to mentally
prepare i always tell her stuff like
10 12 kids um for real you're trying to
make real ken just you know what i mean
how old kids you want two dance groups
28 um rivaling dancing trying to make
two dance groups well the thing is
it's like it sounds funny in our
generation but like my dad's like
uh fourth oldest of 12. wow and my mom's
the youngest of eight
but your dad also has depression right
no i'm just kidding
just kidding yeah depression when you
had me but after that was all right
how many siblings you got i only have
one older sister oh oh
yeah so you feel like that family's too
small
well it's always it's about like well to
me it's always about the growing up
experience as kids right i have like a
bunch of cousins here on like the west
coast yeah so anytime families get
together you're just like playing with
the shitload of kids
whereas i look at like my sister who's
my one sister and her kids
so i have a niece and nephew but i don't
have any children yet so in terms of
like their direct
cousins that are like around there's
nothing yeah you know what i'm saying so
like when i think about big families i
don't actually just think about like the
next
generation it's almost like even like
multiple generations i'm like how that
kind of just
everybody wants to build a little army
right you know you know what's crazy i'm
gonna be like genghis khan
you know that's my dream uh hawks the
only child
both of his parents are only children
children
child or child oh yeah that's crazy like
last two generations of china right it's
insane
right with like the one child lost so
it's like that's also how families get
rich though
no i'm trying to mentally prepare for so
settle for like
seven i'll [ __ ] settle for one if we
get lucky i mean i'm gonna be thankful
at the end of the day but
um i it would be great to have a few
children
if i could afford it you're not scared
of her [ __ ] being destroyed
no my dick is this big okay but the
baby's gonna be bigger than that
he's like oh okay yeah that's true
that's true that's true i mean
it's true you didn't even think about
the beast that's funny
i mean i honestly at the end of the day
it's it's it's a
i can say whatever i want but it comes
down to like how she feels how it goes
down
if we get lucky you know what i mean
like i've heard a lot of stories i've
seen a lot of situations you know from
especially from people in our generation
um so at this point they ate too much
mcdonald's and they can't have a baby
yeah it would just be great to get lucky
you know what i'm saying that's the
reason joe
[Music]
do